it's interesting that in a show that so
many people are watching so closely a
much discussed scene from a trailer
turned out to be something completely
different than it looked like it was
especially in an episode where the
characters connections to reality are
strained to the point of seeming less
reliable than they ever have the scene
in question is what was presumed to be
the new character Jen foaming at the
mouth because of rabies or some similar
sickness this would lead to her death
and that would present the group with
more complicated decisions also it
seemed like a foregone conclusion that
Nat would kill the Moose to provide food
for the rest of the winter and that
might spark debates about it being a
reward from the Wilderness sanity to
help soothe the dissonance from eating
the queen bee neither of these
situations materialized which I think
was a nice surprise but that doesn't
mean that the idea of an IT wanting
blood is off the table unlike Ben I did
not minor in chillaxing so there was a
lot in this episode that got me thinking
primarily the idea of not being able to
know if what we're seeing is real that
sounds like a bad thing but I thought it
worked well there was also a shift in
the visual language to reflect this with
some newish looking Transitions and some
Optical clues for when something's going
on with the characters this was most
apparent in Ben's flashback scenes these
fill in some backstory that after
watching him abstain from eating Jackie
with the rest of the group last week
feels like it's setting up his eventual
ending the story boils down to him being
closeted which we already knew but we
get a better idea of where his head was
at before the trip his unwillingness to
move in with his boyfriend Paul had
strained the relationship he used the
team's great season and not wanting to
let them down as an excuse but his
partner could see through that the idea
is that he was unable to be his true
self and now that he's stranded in the
wilderness slowly starving to death with
the group of young women he described as
vicious little monsters he's imagining
what his life could have been his first
vision seems like a real memory in the
middle of that we see him hallucinate
that scene with Jen foaming at the mouth
which emphasizes this new sense of fear
he has as an outsider the second vision
is him imagining his life if he decided
not to come he goes to Paul to tell him
he's decided to live his life how he was
meant to you see the news of the plane
crash on TV and realized that none of
this happened and it's really just him
in bed starving thinking of how things
could have been different towards the
end of Misty's monologue Travis goes to
talk to him and we see that there's
definitely something wrong this all
worked pretty well to make the character
more interesting and give us a look at
where things are for the survivors
emotionally it does feel like it's the
stuff that will make his death hit all
that much harder but this show is known
to swerve at times so we'll have to see
how things develop from here and while
we're on the subject pretty much
everything pertaining to fleshing out
the characters we haven't seen as
survivors in the present time feels the
same way I am always in awe whenever I
can see someone
coming someone else
it's not that hard
bees and blood were also near the top of
the list of things I was thinking of
because since we haven't spent as much
time with her as we have with the other
adult versions we're still getting to
know adult Lottie and she's a little
hard to figure out on the one hand she's
a cult leader but despite how woo-woo it
all feels it does appear that there's
some sincerity inside of her and her
trying to help her followers and last
episode her retelling of the night
Travis died seems suspicious but at the
end of this episode her reaction to her
vision of the blood and the beehives
hints that there's more going on below
the carefully presented surface that
we've seen thus far none of it makes me
rethink my overall impression and I do
sort of trust Nat's instincts but it
does make it feel like it's moving in a
good direction as I half-heartedly
guessed in my episode 2 video Ty didn't
remember eating Jackie's face at the
banquet and she has a very different
reaction compared to everyone else the
morning after she's mortified and when
van confirms what they did she vomits
everyone else had some time to let it
sink in and because they all
participated they're able to more or
less move on Mari who has been making it
a habit of saying some pretty awful
things when she says I guess no one
wants breakfast it feels pretty true to
life no one feels great about this but
what can they really say they were
hungry and food was provided I'm sure
this isn't the last they'll think about
it but in the moment Nat decides to take
her remains to the crash site and Lottie
decides that they should have a baby
shower for Shawna the episode title is
DJ Steve which is a drink you have to
aid in digestion after you eat and I
suppose there aren't a lot of drinks to
go around that strip to the plane isn't
productive as far as bagging the Moose
but there's some interesting character
stuff going on here these two weren't
close so it stands out that she's the
person who wanted to do something the
idea that Jackie's lucky because she's
free from the suffering the rest are in
for and her line way to make everyone
jealous of you one last time were
particularly effective seeing some of
the reactions that are out there I think
a lot of people are talking about adult
Shauna's monologue which we'll get to in
a bit which don't get me wrong was great
and did a lot to start to bring that
storyline into Focus but I thought this
act of not saying these words out loud
just talking to her remains all by
herself there nobody else to hear it or
for it to matter it's just really a
personal situation I thought that was
one of the best moments of the episode
there's also the point here that she
refuses to drink the tea the fact that
they're full for the time being brings
up the idea of what else they might be
hungering for refusing the T reinforces
that Nat's fearful that Lottie can
provide something to Travis that she
can't and that makes you wonder about
how this moose will come to influence
things going forward in this Scene It
seems more symbolic than anything else a
majestic albino animal that also happens
to be huge and what would provide a
bounty of calories and that is in the
unique position to track it down and
kill it to secure their ability to
survive the winter if she were able to
do that it would prove her worth
something more practical than what
lottie's offering but it's also this
weird symbol so it could lead Nat on her
own spiritual journey if they wanted to
go that way it doesn't come up at the
baby shower though so we'll have to wait
and see the shower itself was mostly a
bust after the initial excitement
everyone had at the chance to get their
minds off the cannibalism but there were
several interesting details that popped
up along the way in the conversation
where the idea came from Lottie told
Shauna that she won't hurt the baby and
refers to it as a hymn more than that
when Shauna questions her it looks like
she tries to play it off but you get the
sense that this is something that she
believes to be true the way she reacted
made me wonder if she's having regular
visions that we haven't seen and she's
keeping them to herself in this moment
Shauna seems accepted to what she's
saying but this will all fall apart
later when she gives her a baby blanket
with the symbol sewn in it Nat thinks
this is a creepy idea and objects and we
see some signs of division within the
group Net's point is that they
discovered it when they discovered the
corpse in the Attic Lottie believes he
was using the symbol for protection so
that reminds her that he died Akila Mari
and Misty agree with Lottie saying that
she's seen things and taisa quickly
interjects that she's not God it looks
like it could get heated but then Shauna
gets a nosebleed and right after a drop
drips onto the symbol everything gets
interrupted by the sound of birds
falling from the sky all around the
cabin when they go outside they see this
kind of thing that can happen but
knowing that doesn't make it any less
weird when it does I thought it was
strange when they were trying to come up
with the rational answer of what might
have happened that Misty declared that
they knew that there was a lot of iron
in the ground and I had to think back to
when this my might have come up before
back in season one when taisa had the
plan that she wanted to try to hike her
way out of there and the group split up
they came across that red stream that
seemed to fulfill lottie's vision of a
river of blood Misty throws out the idea
that minerals can change the color and
Tai instantly adopts that as the reason
why it happened and I guess that's what
they're referring to here is that
they've all decided that this is
confirmation that there's a lot of iron
in the ground and apparently this can
confuse Birds to the point of them
falling from the sky I didn't do a ton
of research but wasn't able to find much
evidence of this being a thing that
happens either what it makes me think of
is they're plane crashing in this
particular place but overall the blood
dripping on the symbol seems at the very
least to be something that they'll be
thinking about and we see Shauna drop
the blanket when she makes the
connection Lottie suggests that they
should collect the birds and she says it
as they should gather its blessings and
we see the group split up again van Mari
Misty Crystal Aquila and Travis start to
collect the birds and tie Nat Shauna and
everyone else head inside the scene ends
with a shot from the upstairs window
which makes you think of the body they
found there that the internet has taken
to calling cabin Daddy to wrap things up
in the 1996 timeline we get some
insights into Crystal and Misty's new
friendship it turns out that Crystal
might be weird Beyond just being an
awkward theater kid but I also think
she's right that they should have
listened to Misty and made some Jackie
bone broth after they bond over the fact
that they kind of enjoyed eating human
flesh Crystal drops the freaky fact that
this wasn't the first time she's eaten a
person it's not so much that she
absorbed her identical twin in the womb
but the looks on her face when she's
revealing this to Misty when she was
first introduced I was worried that
Misty might take her down a dark path
but this makes me wonder if they'll
happily go down one together other I
just had somebody till they feel as bad
as I do I just want to hit something I
want to hit it on Misty does a
surprisingly good job with her monologue
from Steel Magnolias and it was
interesting to see everyone who was
skeptical sort of come around to it at
the end what jumped out the most was the
look she had on her face at the end
though it's not entirely clear where
they're heading with this yet but it
seems like there's a spark inside of her
that wasn't there before as I mentioned
Ty was not awake during the feast and
this was a big surprise for Van perhaps
so much of a surprise that she isn't
subtle in reminding her partner that she
ate the face later when she gets up the
Sleepwalk again van tells her that
she'll let her go if she can go along we
get some Clues as to what's going on
with Ty when this happens she says she
follows the one with no eyes when tide
lets her so this altar version does
exist completely independent of Thai and
we don't actually know if she sees the
man with no eyes here but she walks
straight to a tree with the symbol
carved on it there she wakes up and
tells van she doesn't know who the one
with no eyes is which kind of feels like
a lie none of it's absolutely clear but
it does seem that she has no memory of
what happened and she also doesn't
remember drawing the symbol on Simone's
hand in the present day again that's not
exactly surprising since we've known
that she does some strange things while
she's sleepwalking I was a little
surprised that this thing that she's
been seeing since childhood might be
connected to the symbol there isn't
enough to even say that though since we
don't know what the symbol actually is
it's entirely possible that this man
with no eyes isn't connected to it at
all but sees it as something that might
help them get out of there after the
nurse asks her about what she Drew on
Simone's hand she wipes it off and then
goes into the bathroom where we see
another one of these mere situations
where the reflection is doing its own
thing this time Tai eventually notices
it too and when she asks what it wants
it mouths the words go to her and puts
her hands over her face to indicate that
she's talking about van Ty leaves the
hospital after acquiring the keys to her
campaign manager's car we also see that
she tries to call Jessica Roberts on the
way out who we don't expect will answer
since as far as we know she was killed
by Misty in the season one finale this
was all very intriguing and I'm looking
forward to her reunion with adult van
the rumors had been that she'd show up
in episode 4 and it looks like that will
turn out to be true I've been pretty
forthcoming about the mixed feelings I
get sometimes when it comes to the
present day timeline and this episode
managed to deliver some of the best
stuff we've seen there and some of the
worst in one go as much as I was looking
forward to it I thought Randy's
interrogation fell flat and the whole
setup and carjacking part of Jeff and
Shauna's story was Goofy both of these
situations produce some things that are
important but some of the times when
this show is trying to be funny me it
just doesn't land for me when it does it
does though so I guess you take the good
with the bad the new dynamic duo of
African gray and putting the sick and
forensics did manage to get a clue about
purple clothes and Fanta soda that will
lead them to lottie's compound though
there is a lot of potential in chemistry
here so I'm highly optimistic I can't
say that I understand why Misty lied to
Walter about knowing Adam's mother this
seems like an unforced error that might
come back on her considering it should
be fairly easy for someone like him to
disprove and remember Cali couldn't find
anything on the internet about him in
the first place so that might cause
problems too I find it curious that
Walter seems to be loaded that they made
a point that he had money I wonder how
that's going to affect things and also
not sure why he referred to himself as a
Moriarty looking for a Sherlock since
those two are more like Arch enemies
than anything else there are a lot of
ways that this situation Jason can go
wrong but you still kind of want to see
this work out and it all makes me wonder
what she was thinking when she smiled
after reading his text about their
upcoming Road Trip the Jeff and Shawna
side of things also hit some highs which
was good to see because this had been
dragging for me Jeff's impromptu trip to
Colonial Williamsburg was fantastic as
was the conversation about the
strawberry lube and her explanation
about how she liked not knowing what
would happen when she was with Adam this
is the exact opposite of what we see the
teenage Shauna talking to Lottie about
back in 96. it makes you wonder how much
you actually know her in the present
because based on what we see here she's
pretty out of control after she takes
the gun off the carjacker Jeff is so
shocked that he basically lets the guy
get away with their minivan later she
goes and tracks it down to a junkyard
and we get to see a side of her that we
may have thought was there but we really
haven't seen to this point the owner of
the junkyard makes the mistake of
judging her to be what she looks like he
thinks that she's a scared housewife who
would never be able to pull the trigger
she quickly gets him to reconsider this
notion by explaining the process of
peeling the skin off a human body in a
way that you could only do if you had
done it before the whole thing is
intense and definitely makes me believe
that they're going to hunt and eat
multiple people before they're rescued
she finishes off her speech by
explaining that her hand wasn't shaking
holding the gun because she was afraid
it was shaking because of how badly she
wanted to kill him the delivery makes an
impression and she gets her minivan back
but it also feels like she was telling
the truth which makes this Shauna story
in the present day a lot more compelling
Jeff wasn't nearly as successful in his
foolish attempt to talk to Kevin tan at
the gym the sedakis are three for three
as far as striking out while talking to
the police Kevin's telling Jeff about
the affair would have been brutal if he
didn't already know and it was kind of
funny that his source is Cali the bottom
line here is that this situation isn't
going away in Shauna's current
trajectory of doing crazier things each
week might add a dimension of danger to
that going back to where we started with
adult Lottie apparently Nat has decided
to stay on the compound rather than head
back plot wise this isn't surprising but
it isn't clear yet why she changed her
mind if I had to guess it's because she
wants to figure out what lottie's up to
she spends most of the episode lurking
around while Lottie tries to integrate
her with the group and get her to
participate they're still at odds with
each other just like they were back in
the wilderness and when Lottie shows her
The Beehive she tells her a story that
seems relevant to the time they spent
there she explains that in the winter
time the other bees cluster around the
queen and vibrate to keep her warm she
says that the first thing a new Queen
does when it hatches is saying all the
other unborn Queens to death and says
that that isn't brutal it's natural it's
simply what has to be done otherwise
they all starve this with all the antler
imagery around the compound makes it
sound like it's all alluding to her time
as the antler Queen if you think about
the team's Hive Dynamics they failed to
protect Jackie their de facto Queen from
freezing to death in the winter a lot of
the teens then start to look at Lottie
as her replacement with the obvious
exception of nat so this comes off as
her justifying some of her decisions or
actions in the period of time that we
haven't seen yet the in-between time
it's a neat story but it kind of just
comes off as more new age culty vibes
from Lottie until the end of the episode
where they add another dimension as this
week's Tori Amos song bells for you
plays and we hear the lyrics Can't Stop
what's coming can't stop what's on its
way Lottie returns to the beehives to
find them all dead when she opens is the
Box Simone Castle does a terrific job of
conveying the complex emotions that
she's experiencing when she pulls out
one of the frames and sees it's covered
in blood as she's looking at her hands
and trying to figure out what happened
we hear a voice say
in French when she turns to ask this
follower what she just said she realizes
it was all a vision when she repeats her
question are you joining for lunch
Lottie looks spooked and the episode
cuts to Black when you think about
Lottie and French who think back to the
Seance from season one while they were
having that she started saying something
very similar to if not exactly this same
phrase Jackie points out that Lottie was
bad in French class so the fact that
she's speaking the language is
surprising already and even though
Jackie was bad at it too she manages to
translate what she was saying to either
he or it wants blood The Beehive Vision
feels slightly different than the vision
she had when Travis was dying because
she's just here alone at the compound
and the idea of it wanting blood seems
to really shake her up is this because
of things that happened in the past or
is this her being afraid of what she
might do the fear she's experiencing is
in stark contrast from the image she's
projecting to her followers for me this
works to make the adult character feel
essential to everything that's going on
and I'm looking forward to learning more
about how she deals with these Visions
she's having in the past there was a
sense that she saw things before they
happen so what does that mean in
relation to this vision of death and the
idea that it wants blood I can't wait to
find out in the rest of the season I
thought that this episode felt like
things were starting to settle in for
this new season the Ben flashbacks felt
a little more disconnected from what's
Happening than the ones that we've seen
from the girls throughout the show but I
guess that makes sense since he was
never really one of them it also makes
sense that he tried to continue his role
as an authority figure gear since he's
the only adult there and the one that
would ultimately have to answer
questions if they were rescued but I
wonder if this thinking about his
regrets regarding his boyfriend is being
sparked by things that are happening in
the cabin if this isn't all setting him
up to die then I wonder if it's setting
him up to leave that role behind and to
Echo what he told Paul start to live his
life as he was meant to whatever that
might mean in this post-cannibalism
survival situation that they're in he's
always felt like a bit of an outsider to
the rest of the group because of the age
difference now he is a literal Outsider
because he didn't eat Jackie and he used
to function in a way that he was their
last connection to civilization if you
will so it's kind of exciting to think
about what might happen to him we didn't
get any updates on the hobby situation
and generally not much concerning Travis
it seemed a little weird that he didn't
go with Nat to the plane in light of the
Visions he was having with Lottie in
their intimate moments but they were all
in a weird way after the banquet so I'm
not sure what to make of it as of yet I
mentioned that they were adding
Dimensions to some of the characters at
different points in this recap and there
was also a lot related to story lots of
blood lots of mentions of and it and
lots of references to the symbol where
last week I was a little put off by the
supernatural feeling behind the way they
shot the snow dropping on Jackie's
funeral pyre I really like this idea of
the blood falling on the symbol on
shawna's baby blanket and then these
birds falling from the sky because this
is more about how they'll react to that
I wouldn't say they came up with a great
rational explanation but things like
this do happen and we watched in real
time how opinions were divided and they
actually split up while some of the
people were picking up the birds as
offerings that's a new minor mystery and
there's others like the sound of
Dripping that mari's hearing it seems
like she's the only one that's hearing
that so I'm not sure where that's going
Walter is fun but he's also kind of a
suspicious character there's definitely
something there as far as why he
initially came looking for African gray
the white moose could be a new thing it
kind of came and went in the episode
itself but I imagine that there will be
more related to that in the future in
the terror that Lottie experiences when
she has these visions and what that
means about what happened in the past I
mean the fact that she still uses the
symbol that we see it all over her
compound the fact that we see those
antlers outside of her quarters and we
see them as part of the design inside it
certainly felt like she was using those
experiences to guide what she does with
her followers so this Terror this fear
that she's experiencing makes that all a
lot more complicated this character Lisa
that Nat stabbed at lottie's compound is
getting a fair amount of screen time the
theory that's been floating around the
internet was that this is Shauna's baby
because the actor is the right age the
idea being that no one knew Shawna was
pregnant so it would be possible for
Lottie to claim the baby was hers when
they got rescued it's mostly a fun
Theory because there isn't much evidence
and it seemed like it might be debunked
after Lottie referred to the baby as a
boy interesting enough Nicole Maines who
plays Lisa is trans so her being born in
the wilderness could still make sense
now that Nat and Travis are sleeping
together it's even possible that Nat
could get pregnant out there but there
would be some explaining that would need
to be done for her not to have mentioned
anything about the child she gave up to
Lottie by this point I'm very excited to
see adult tie in band reunite and find
out what she's been up to since the
rescue it was a surprise to see the bad
ones suggest that she go looking for her
with Misty and Walter following the
Fanta Trail to Lottie it seems like a
reasonable guess that van might want to
go there too Ty left the hospital in a
hurry so I do hope that she didn't
forget about Steve and Sammy I'm also
looking forward to more visions and
possibly some more unreliable narrators
I like the emphasis on the fact that all
of these characters are having a little
bit of trouble with their grip on
reality there doesn't seem to be
anything that's ongoing what I mean is
here we saw Ben thinking of what might
have been but also by the end of the
scene it was clear what was happening so
as long as it doesn't get to a point
where nothing matters because we don't
know if it's real or not I'm here for it
and I think that is a great place to
leave things please like this video If
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon